mi sono salvato la faccia dell'inter va
scoraggiato numero di soldati
per un basco scompare dalla scuola e
questo è un segnale da cui dobbiamo
scappare pronte iniziamo subito credevo
carnate dunque mi piace vedere cosa
dirvi e allora dobbiamo scegliere
modalità facili o difficili non facile
con facile perché se non si sente l
avevo tantissime volte
facciamo ciò nella classe e la prima
persona figlio che mi siedo qui però
spetta ho preso topolino che ho fatto
non vedono intento a polino che è ma non
hai nessun banco e mano grave dove di
natuzzi forse lo vedo solo io prendo la
sedia si banco anche
cecco l'insegnate il
il maestro ma li possiamo regalare una
maglietta così si copre quella paris
fatta e sono tramite un pannello ma non
dobbiamo farci scoprire ma perché non
possiamo prendere i marchi che cosa
dovremmo fare forse lo dovrebbe
incastrare li guarda
ci sono sopratutto la faccia
ha scoraggiato
questa giunta sembra già essere molto
divertente ma mercato air india monti
affitto
[Musica]
allora si è scritto nella lavagna allora
le regole sono non disturberò mister
fico sarebbe questo maestro mister p.col
vuol dire mister cerri invito
non proverò a scappare dalla punizione
noi certo che scopre voi e non metterò
delle bombe puzzolenti in classe
possiamo mettere delle bombe puzzolenti
che intendo la scorreggia no forse
qualcos'altro non lo so perché con la
campanella dobbiamo cliccare qui forse
allora sta qui presentata non lo so ho
cliccato un pulsante ma non è successo
niente ma cosa dobbiamo andare quattro
avversari che questo c'è bisogno d'amore
ma anche le streghe è certo ok allora
mettiamo il banco qui ci sono un sacco
di altri giocatori poi saliamo sul banco
budel aspetti mi basta visto
ed era stato mi piace estere l'avete
ancora stato mi raccomando chi sono gli
piace qui
che cosa c'è qui
delle scarpe con le fiamme sbarca anche
wow
si sente ancora mettersi torino
si chiuda nel ci credo di fitalia
moderata
ok concentrazione a vita con
centroavanti vitale mi ha superato gli
otto
mesi sono laggiù
scrivete nei commenti domanda per voi
preferite i giochi in prima persona
oppure quelli normali i quali sono i
giochi prima persona questo che in prima
persona quindi non vedete il mio
personaggio da fuori ma vedete tipo le
mani cioè e proprio come se mano come
anche voi foste il personaggio vedete
dal punto di vista che per sono pure in
rete vitale
dai sbrighiamocì dobbiamo battere tutti
gli altri giocatori viola
mi sono scaricato in quelle punte a ma
anche tu no
no no davvero finita o sono tornata qui
devi essere un tacco i giochi in prima
persona perché è più bello vedere in
prima persona però sono molto più
difficili c'è io cado un sacco di goldin
che mio fratello molto di più perché
prendere le misure
ma cosa serve questo puntante
non fare danni a rita ha forse nata per
attivare leve
886 riuscito andare avanti è certo
tantissimo
si no
un giorno prima che arrivi il mister si
trova
ok siamo di nuovo qua va ancora male
dovevi stare
brava è stata di nuovo
ascoltata
dai
vari dobbiamo salire qua sopra
contesse aspetto m
allora dice che c'è il bottone per un
ascensore
che hanno amato
eccolo ok perfetto via ciao c'è qualcuno
perché centro d'arte in capitanata
vabbè
ho preso un
collega dobbiamo salire qui ho capito
tutto ok iniziamo dobbiamo fare le cose
si vecchio ma no io metterei una scala
direttamente perché c'è scala è previsto
molto meglio dei vari specchi è però è
troppo poco
ci vuole qualcos'altro da mettere sulla
scala italiana
alla scala non basta portare se un
pulsante o quando mito lisbona ok
proviamo a mettere la scatola qua sopra
a scappare una vasca dove
fatta è riuscito a passare si son
passato
no sono caduta lo ha pure tu sei caduta
credo che fini dobbiamo cadere ma ok e
adesso siamo nelle tubature della scuola
e buttando nei seminterrati sono tornati
a scuola stiamo scappando più nelle
tubature voglio esplorare bene questa
scuola che sapremo la scuola di baldi
apriamo
lo fanno e mandare a picco di armadietti
forse è una scuola americano todd un
potavoce
set
ecuadoriano maglietta
ma confesso di maglietta è appreso
lo fa questa volta ero velocissimo tu
sei riuscito a scappare si sta dentro me
so fondatore è così apriamo la porta non
sia pronta ci sono una chiave ci voleva
chiave guarda una chiave rotta
aspetta adesso mister piccolo mi ha
preso pro vasto 2
dove serie di tutti tronto dove mister
petrolino
o ancora a chi a tema dove va preso e
deve andare mi sembrava allora sì l'ho
trovata ho trovato aprire
presto presto presto prima che avrei mai
un cucciolo dietro dai dai non mi
riporto dovete con davis è riuscito a
passare il decreto sono proprio qui
vicino alla porta dovuto un aprirla ad
entrare se non arriva mister centrolido
ce la posso fare anche le eccomi
siamo in palestra come possiamo fare
dirlo ma come mai è così alta e poi era
apposta per farci sfracellare
saliamo e trenino ho pensato tutto
un trampolino è bello motore
ok ok è invece devi tenere l'equilibrio
dobbiamo salire su quindi piano che anni
non c'è problema per questo
che i fronti la via che figo aspetta
allora quindi qui può superare evitare
guarda bisogna premere il bottone
lanciarci
io voterò per ma niente che volava
tocca a
chi siamo
[Musica]
io sono ancora vivo in mezzo al primo
braccio e la mente di un per forse una
riparto d'acqua in onda capo è troppo
divertente queste stefano
guardate evitare la giocava ottica
[Musica]
ok mi manca l'ultimo
dai mali che parte della scuola sospette
allora sembra che per entrare qui
dobbiamo fare canestro con la palla o ci
prendiamo una panna e proviamo a fare
canestro vediamo se ci
vai subito
aspetta aspetta c'è mister piccoli io
non ce l'ho fatto perché sono persi ma
non ho mira tutti i giochi in cui
bisogna avere mira per me sono terribili
bravissimo dai punta più in alto da
un'altra parabola sci fi una mira eterna
e punta nel quadrato più basso
bravissima ceri quasi
voi fate qualche sport scriveteci nei
commenti che sport fabio betto forchetta
indietro
allora questo piatto non tira mai
indietro ma è più dietro milano il
quadrato che sta all'interno bravo vai
era già fatta
più di certo che il vicino possibile un
occhio indietro che dietro che ok vai
adesso
ma perché era genova ai ragazzi vi
avviso che saremo fermi qua per 40 ok
vedere
dai riprova vai adesso ce la fai no non
così in alto
abbiamo niente petrolio sta correndo da
mucca conseguenti aiuto ora sara piu
veloce nel freddo si corre in aiuto mi
ha ricordato un po basi
per la caffetteria no non andare lì solo
perché c'è il cibo sto andando qui nel
bagno
sì credo che dobbiamo proprio andare nel
e riproviamo allora
vi abbiamo
girato
ma forse ci dovevamo nascondere avete
con essa
adesso lo vedi lo scopriremo allora sto
provando a vedere se c'è qualcosa di
mina scusarci qua dentro
no
gabinetto
ok questa volta ce la facciamo ragazzi
nero il rumore delle sgommate di mister
cetriolino ecco roma chiudere subito la
porta compreso
dai puoi farcela degli stadi la cornell
nel secondo non secondo va bene ok
cosa non mi ha preso però scopriamo
allora ok io seguo the queen e labirinti
siamo tornati tv no
anche voi vento che bello adesso ci
becchiamo delle risate coralità che
sbaglierà sempre avevo già preso
aspetta aspettiamo che arrivi qua
è stato più facile questo che a canestro
e ora definiremo sembrano di nuovo delle
ventole che ci porteranno in alto
qualunque cosa ci sono i laser si vuole
forse adesso cosa facciamo passare da
presa sono stato preso dai laser ok ce
l'hanno fatta a economy voce aspettare
non riesco a spostarmi da riempire la
giu no dettato arrosticini e qui
dopo essere stato custodito un poetico
la vita vai tu davanti perché non so
dove lo aspetta però dobbiamo scendere
di nuovo gioco ma perché ci ha fatto
salire se poi dobbiamo invece andrea
bairati che la strada giusta non lo so
magari abbiamo sbagliato ok siamo
tornati a scuola
attento lui è lì dove a no no scusa ho
sbagliato
siamo dentro sembra la caffetteria
questa è la regia è una bibita gola lì
che ti fa la supervelocità mi sarà o no
sace bambolina un sacco di volte per me
va benissimo con la social velocità
speriamo che
adesso anche il salto superveloce
e super divertente
avete visto vitale bonaria dell'oblio
è lunghissimo questo stage
[Musica]
e così ciao molti restituto mido
raggiungermi si è anche disconnesso
abbiamo perso vitale poverino server mi
ha buttato fuori ma ora a finire queste
skype roma fai per te
questo sì caro signor lotto
porterà quella vita è vero ma vero la
guarda no c'è la macchina dopo il muro a
uno il precedente non era il go kart e
dobbiamo fare la gara con lui
perché non ci sono io adesso ti hanno
dato una ferrari a teheran è visto
a tutto gas
o no ma è velocissimo lui
[Musica]
a me sembra di andré pieni ma mai
tradito
le fiamme addirittura tiro gira
ora mi ha superato
l'uomo è bellissimo questo è diventato
mario kart 9 scaduti non ci sono io a
correre con la macchina anche
a mia cugina
addio
di prima
si deve andare a destra prova sinistra a
destra sinistra
[Musica]
più dove hanno superato vero si sono
prima
[Musica]
ci siamo quasi
consiglieresti curarsi troppo bravo sei
berlino madrid con i go kart nella
scuola comunque veramente il top e con
il professore anche ma non è finita
a re adesso ci sono degli spunti da qui
da qui guarda c'è una freccia
ma se devo applicare poi c'è un entrata
di narni
poi bravo ok e ora devi stare superando
attento a non cadere
ma piano piano
tale caduta uno strano
piano
daiki sui magri dal centralino no non
c'è più tranquilla bene bene ancora
piangendo perché ha perso la gara
diventa
[Musica]
venite ce la puoi fare lasciate un bel
like e portando fortuna tali da questa
volta non a me perché di solito sono io
quello che aspetta la vostra fortuna dai
dai dai vi facciamo noi siamo affatto
ok ce lo farà male che non avete idea di
quante volte mi sono sprezzo della 184
[Musica]
guardate la c'è mister ci parlino con
dei bazooka ho come l'impressione che
dovremmo fare una battaglia finale ok
per il momento forse è meglio scappare
mandatemi qualcosa per per combattere
guarda
che io che cosa che fate questa cosa è
una cannuccia spara palline
cercate questo sempre meno
attento
ci sei quasi ci sei quasi che lo puoi
fare
ancora ancora può cerca di scappare belo
brava brava
manca poco ancora tra un quattro volti
forza 5 6 7 8
bravissimo
che sta sparando
dobbiamo prendere pure è viva
vediamo
ma non
posso dare io
devo guidare il figlio
[Musica]
manca volante non fa parte sta partendo
eccoci qua tu mi sei arrivato a prendere
gol
è
stato bravo bel mi piace è rovinato
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
anche su quella che preferite